[Music]  Rhianna stunning at the 69th annual  parsons benefit in new york city Monday  night I love when fashion and  philanthropy can come together and  that's what tonight is all about I love  when fashion and film can come together  ET chatted with RiRi just after reports  surfaced that she and Lupita Nyong'o had  signed on for a Netflix movie inspired  by oh yes that Twitter meme about this  picture Rihanna and Lupita would play  scammers in the film with Ava Duvernay  reportedly directing an ISA ray on board  - right - my favorite style icons you  and Lupita Nyong'o are going to do this  movie - the internet really well you  never know  I mean we'll just have to wait and see  well everyone's been buzzing today ok so  bad girl kind of left us hanging but we  did get her to spill this your favorite  fashion moment that you've had oh shoot  I don't know if I should say that cuz I  was kind of naked today it baby  I'm is this all about timing  [Music]